>> Laura: EARLIER THIS WEEK,
WE BROUGHT YOU REPORTING FROM
MINNEAPOLIS THAT THE CITY IS
STILL REELING FROM THE GEORGE
FLOYD RIOTS OF TWO YEARS AGO.
BUSINESSES IN MANY CASES STILL
HAVEN'T REOPENED, AND THE CITY
IS EXPERIENCING A MASSIVE
CRIME WAVE.
39% RISE IN MURDERS COMPARED
TO 2019.
RESIDENTS THERE, THEY HAVE NO
IDEA IF THEIR CITY IS EVER
GOING TO BE REBUILT IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
HECK, PEOPLE DON'T EVEN FEEL
SAFE SHOPPING ANYMORE.
YESTERDAY AT THE MALL OF
AMERICA JUST NINE MILES
OUTSIDE OF MINNEAPOLIS, RANDOM
GUNFIRE HAD PANICKED FAMILIES
SCRAMBLING.
MINNEAPOLIS IS GROUND ZERO FOR
MINNESOTA'S DECLINE.
THE DISTRICT IS REPRESENTED
NONE OTHER THAN ILHAN OMAR.
INSTEAD OF FIGHTING FOR THE
CITIZENS TO BE SAFER, SHE'S
FIGHTING TO DEFUND THE
ALREADY-DEPLETED POLICE FORCE.
NOW, FINALLY, IT TURNS OUT THE
COMMUNITY IS SICK OF HER
ANTICS.
THE STAR TRIBUNE AND EVEN UBER
LEFTY MAYOR JACOB FREY HAVE
NOW ENDORSED HER PRIMARY
OPPONENT, A GUY NAMED DON
SAMUELS.
IS ANOTHER DEMOCRAT REALLY THE
ANSWER?
JOINING ME NOW IS JIM SCHULTZ
WHO IS RUNNING TO UNSEAT
ANOTHER RADICAL IN THE STATE,
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEITH
ELLISON.
NOW, JIM, YOU CALL ELLISON THE
POLITICAL GODFATHER OF ILHAN
OMAR.
WHY AND WHEN DID THIS STATE GO
SO RADICAL?
>> PRETTY RECENTLY, LAURA.
GREAT TO BE ON WITH YOU.
ELLISON WAS ELECTED IN 2006.
SHE SUCCEEDED HIM.
HE'S HER POLITICAL GODFATHER.
THEY EMBRACED THE RADICAL DEEP
ON THE POLICE POLICIES THAT
LED TO THE EXTRAORDINARY
VIOLENCE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: WELL, I WAS SO
SADDENED, BECAUSE AS YOU MAY
KNOW, I SPENT QUITE A BIT OF
TIME IN MINNESOTA.
EVERY YEAR, I'VE BEEN GOING
THERE FOR 15 YEARS FOR THE
SUMMER, AND IT'S JUST SO
BEAUTIFUL!
IT'S SUCH A WONDERFUL STATE!
THE TWIN CITIES, MINNEAPOLIS,
IT'S JUST SUCH A -- IT'S A
VIBRANT COMMUNITY.
NEVER FELT UNSAFE THERE.
AND THEN... THE LAWLESSNESS
CAME IN AFTER FLOYD, AND
THEN --
>> YEP.
YEP.
>> Laura: PEOPLE WONDER IF
THERE'S ANY WAY TO TURN IT
AROUND NOW.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT!
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN A PAINFUL
FEW YEARS IN THE STATE.
YOU KNOW, I GREW UP IN THE
STATE.
I'M A FIFTH-GENERATION
MINNESOTAN AND I THINK I FEEL
IT AND MINNESOTANS FEEL IT
GENERALLY WE'RE LOSING THE
STATE WE HAVE KNOWN AND LOVED.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE RADICAL
POLICIES EMBRACED BY PEOPLE
LIKE KEITH ELLISON AND ILHAN
OMAR AND OUR TERRIBLE GOVERNOR
TIM WALZ THAT HAVE LED TO THIS
CURRENT POINT.
I MEAN, I CALL IT A MAN-MADE
DISASTER.
MAN-MADE DISASTER THAT
DESCENDED UPON OUR STATE.
WE HAVE TO TURN IT AROUND
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Laura: NOW, IN ENDORSING
OMAR'S OPPONENT -- OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE RUNNING FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- BUT HER SEAT IS
WHERE -- HER DISTRICT IS WHERE
ALL THE VIOLENCE TOOK PLACE.
THEY SAID OMAR OFTEN APPEARS
DISCONNECTED FROM HER DISTRICT
AND UNWILLING TO WORK WITH
FREY.
OMAR DIDN'T RECOGNIZE THE NAME
AND HAD NO UPON EVEN THOUGH
HIS NOMINATION TO THE
HIGH-PROFILE PUBLIC SAFETY
ROLE WAS PROMINENTLY REPORTED
BY LOCAL NEWS OUTLETS.
UM, SO, JIM, BASICALLY SAYING
SHE DOESN'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
THE DISTRICT.
IT'S MORE ABOUT HER OWN PUBLIC
PROFILE AND BURNISHING THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SHE SEEMS TO SPEND ALL OF HER
TIME IN WASHINGTON THESE DAYS.
SHE'S COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED
FROM THE COMMUNITY, AND
FRANKLY KEITH ELLISON IS
COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED FROM
THE COMMUNITY.
IF THEY WERE CONNECTED TO THE
COMMUNITY, THEY WOULD KNOW
THERE'S AREAS OF NORTH
MINNEAPOLIS THAT HAVE BECOME A
SHOOTING GALLERY.
THERE'S AREAS IN MINNEAPOLIS
AND ST. PAUL WHERE YOU ON ANY
GIVEN DAY MIGHT BE CARJACKED
OR OTHERWISE.
SO THEY END UP EMBRACING THESE
POLICIES THAT HAVE LED TO
SUCH, YOU KNOW, EXTRAORDINARY
CRIME AND VIOLENCE IN OUR
STATE AND SO THESE ARE, YOU
KNOW, TWO KIND OF LIMOUSINE
LIBERALS THAT EMBRACED
POLICIES THAT LED TO
INCREDIBLE VIOLENCE AND
DESTRUCTION IN OUR STATE.
>> Laura: GOOD FOR THE
CRIMINALS.